imagine if you could take in
all of human history in the blink of an
eye
well from the first steps out of the
slime
to the first steps on the moon that's
exactly where we are in cosmic terms but
in that short amount of time we've done
quite a bit what would you see if you
traveled
one billion years into the past
did earth ever look like a giant slush
ball
how far back would you have to go to see
the first humans
and are we already going extinct
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you went one billion years into the
past
[Music]
in a sense we're all time travelers
we travel into the future at the rate of
one second
per second but if you want to go
backward in time
you'll need to go faster than the speed
of light
that's according to einstein or maybe
your time machine would
jump through wormholes a hypothetical
tunnel that connects
two different points in space time
however you decide to travel through the
jumbled mess of time
you'll see the effects and then the
causes
of the most powerful forces that shaped
our world
you might leave wondering how many times
did the earth freeze
as you watch history unfold or refold or
whatever you might be surprised at the
toll
humanity has taken on this planet in
such a short amount of time
if you start in 2021 and move backward
you would watch the sixth mass
extinction event happening
right now known as the holocene
extinction
we are currently living through one of
the most destructive periods of
our time caused by human activity
as humans destroy coral reefs and rain
forests
the numerous wildlife and plants that
depend on these ecosystems
die with them according to the
international union for the conservation
of nature
67 of endangered species
could be extinct in 100 years
and since most of these extinctions are
undocumented
we won't even know about what we've lost
until it's gone
maybe not even then visit the 18th
and 19th centuries and you could watch
the pollution
created by the industrial revolution
reversed
back into the smokestacks cities would
shrink down and return to their roots as
rural farmlands
while this would let you see the
explosion of the human race in terms of
population and pollution if you want to
retrace
our first steps you'll need to go back
farther
tour the planet 200 000 years ago
and you would witness the arrival of our
species
the homo sapiens jump back seven million
years to
northern chad and the oldest known
species of humans
could stroll right by you known as the
cylanthropus
jedensis this mysterious
link in our chain looked ape-like but
was the first to walk upright he seems
friendly enough
if you think you have challenges now
imagine living during
this age you'd need the skills these
early humans learned to survive and
you'd need them fast but if you sign up
with the great courses plus
you can make this year whatever that is
yours by learning with a purpose with
top experts in their fields taking deep
dives into a wide range of subjects
there's something for everyone if you're
spending time with our primitive
ancestors
you might want to take the outdoor
fundamentals course
covering everything from preparation to
navigation
or maybe introduction to paleontology to
mentally prepare you to meet the
spinosaurus the largest carnivore to
ever walk the earth well you can watch
or listen to these lectures on any
device anywhere
with the great courses plus app visit
thegreatcoursesplus.com
what if to get a 14 day trial with
unlimited access
that's the great courses plus dot com
slash
what if you won't have a chance to go
back in time to get this deal and
if you don't study up you might not make
it past the jurassic
era but travel
to 60 million years ago and you'll see
the first primates emerge from the humid
rainforests of asia
okay step back to 65 million years ago
and you'd find yourself under the giant
asteroid that
created a global extinction event
the impact caused a tsunami and filled
the air with
dust and debris the crash also set off
massive volcanic eruptions across the
world
with the sun blacked out and the land
flooding
the last of the dinosaurs died out
but without this event mammals like us
may never have taken over the planet
go back 130 million years and you'll see
the first
flowers bloom as you travel
200 million years back in time you'll
witness
the breakup of pangaea the mass of land
that will become the continents
as the land breaks apart the lava
eruptions will be
so massive they kill almost 80 percent
of the species on earth
okay keep going back another 20 million
years and watch
the first early mammals small and
nocturnal
crawl around in the dark and if you go
back
to 230 million years ago
you could watch the early dinosaurs walk
for the first time on two legs
before that can happen though the earth
has to go through
what would be known as the great dying
also called the permian extinction 95
of all species on earth died
but you could also watch the earth's
land masses
come together to form pangaea now
you could take a walk from argentina to
china
but things get interesting around 375
million years ago
you would watch marine animals walking
onto land for the first time
maybe you would see a titalic which
looks like a salamander
mixed with a fish this strange creature
would later evolve into mammals and
amphibians
but just like every species you saw
before
this growth doesn't happen without a
cost
and now we're at the first extinction
event
the ore division extinction occurs when
ice sheets
spread from the polar caps into the
oceans
almost 70 percent of all sea life
died off during this planet-wide freeze
over 460 million years ago
okay keep going back and you could see
how life started underwater called the
cambrian explosion the lineage of
most of the species on our planet today
can be traced back to this milestone
but scientists are still unsure how this
unique event happened
between 635 and 850
million years ago the earth froze over
twice once for almost 60 million years
and
the next time for 15 million years
one theory suggests that the earth was
only covered in a thin film of ice
allowing the sun's rays to seep through
and plant the seeds of life below
but go back one billion years in history
and you'll be surprised to find well
not a lot during this time
red algae are forming spores to
reproduce
cells are coming together to form larger
organisms
life on earth is microscopic and
not very threatening but nothing has
been
more vicious to our planet in such a
short amount of time
as humans but
maybe humans will set things right
eventually
there could be a change in our planet or
our hearts that might set our future on
a different path
or maybe like the dinosaurs and
neanderthals
we would just be replaced by something
else
so let's take our time machine and find
out
what if you traveled one billion years
into the future
well that's a story for another
what if